I don't really know what to say tonight
might be might be a complete train wreck
I'm very busy thankful Cup right around
the corner I assume by the time you guys
see this the sink field comes over is
that right that sound right think what
comes right over and man what a great
tournament it was it was fantastic I
loved every second of it and I couldn't
believe that one guy clay pulled out
that real big win right in the clutch it
was great
so I've just been busy uh I've spent the
the last ten minutes before this lecture
I had about I'd about three Grand
Master's you know pretty decent ones
helping me out with this lecture so
hopefully I remember anything maybe I
won't maybe I can't set the first puzzle
on power but uh so I was giving it to
them and seeing we know which one of
them's were able to solve it we're gonna
go over some simple studies I'll attempt
to set it up on the board here it's
white to move and there's only one
solution uh uh I think this was the
position so there was one of our
employees here Richard pointer he's this
classic coordinator he was showing this
to a player rigid about 2100 in the club
he the 2100 was able to solve it in
about an hour and I guess you're on the
internet so you know who he is it's
Julian
it's Richard Shaw Julian it took Julian
about an hour so at home you may want to
you know pause the video right now take
a look try to see it's a white to play
and win and I'll just talk a minute
about studies and I guess why they're
important so people have different
ranges on studies I've you know I'm
always fascinated based on people's
approach to studies how they feel about
them I've noticed that the lower rated
you are the more you dislike studies it
feels artificial this is the puzzle you
know this will never happen in a real
game and this is a rather simple one I
mean puzzles can be quite extravagant
with all sorts of really tiny and
visible moves that are impossible to see
but you know solving it is a real task
then it's it's not the kind of thing
that people think oh it's not practical
but on the other hand it does the point
of a study is to really ill
in dramatic fashion a really important
point about chess so in this case it's
gonna be what what to do when there's
the bishop of I can't make can make
things I don't have I can make things
okay when the bishop is in the wrong
color for the corner so this one is I
guess easy to kind of understand the
idea of what white needs to do he needs
to make a queen some studies that you
look at it for a while and you don't
even really understand what the theme is
so tonight's theme is going to be
bishops and of opposite of the out wrong
square and pawns that are trying to get
to that Square and make a queen so it's
gonna be about preventing black from
doing his defensive maneuver so I'll
just ask the class really quick if you
were black and this is sort of an
important point you know you're giving
me the move to your opponent what is
blacks defensive task here what does
black need to do to secure the draw yeah
mm-hmm yeah he needs to just get the
King in the corner so if the King lands
in the corner it's gonna be a well-known
draw you can just shuffle back and forth
it's on for you that's good
so that is the task I will be quiet for
about five minutes I'll come back and
talk so 2,100 player couldn't cook him
at an hour you know at least one Grand
Master was unable to solve it and one
Grand Master was able to solve it in one
second okay it depends on how well you
guys you know how much practice you've
had doing studies obviously but although
I'll be quite here for about five
minutes and uh give the audience a
chance positive videos at home so I've
you know I've been with some of the the
best chess players in the world even
recently too and I've kind of been
talking to him about studies lately and
that seems to be almost exclusively what
some of these guys are doing so the best
players in the world had this is how
they're getting better they're they're
doing studies I assume I was I almost
got to ask Fabiano but he was a little
bit busy for these puzzles just to see
how fast he could solve it because vara
Cobian was here you have one second easy
easy as puzzle he's never seen it in his
life
and it was so easy that he's like well
here's the same theme different puzzle
you know and I showed the spin Feingold
and it was pretty easy and he's like
yeah you know here's a different puzzle
that you know the same theme but harder
easier you know so yes so also if it
were blacks turn let's just let's try to
illuminate a couple of the the options
here if it were blacks turn what move
would he play yeah
kingi one so he's threatening just to go
here and even if you move your Bishop I
just take your pawn and it's a draw
so okay pretty much have to move the
bishop if you move the King anywhere
well then the King just goes and get
your pawn so you got to move your Bishop
so that's that's the first part of the
puzzle so the question is going to be
where and you're going to have to think
a little bit farther into the the future
to see how you're gonna have to blockade
the black King from getting to h8 it is
obviously unfair for the class because
uh you won't get as much time as you can
take at home so in our in our heads
hopefully we're calculating some bishop
moves obviously we have to move our
bishop somewhere and then okay you can
start calculating this pawn is gonna
start going like this and the King is
going to start you know approaching and
trying to run to the corner etc so see
how far you can go with that so you can
even somehow imagine to just put the
bishop somewhere far away in your mind
and start pushing the pawn in your head
and then go with King here Punk and then
try to figure out where you'll need your
your Bishop you can kind of figure that
out in the future where it's gonna need
to be to cut off the King so if if in
your in your head you just play the move
h4 here jumping over your own Bishop and
you start seeing how it works out
Oh guys cuz right cuz this is going to
be your next move let's pretend the
bishops out of the way so you can
imagine blacks next move is gonna be
here and White's move is going to be
here so it's like where do you need your
bishops I'll keep it going the pond
pushes King approaches etc if for
example I mean Bishop f1 let's just see
what happens when you have this little
race here in our heads okay so the King
goes to e3 and we push now all I have to
just get to this corner so I'm gonna go
this way and okay so if you don't push
I'm gonna make it so we kind of see we
get about that far alright so this would
not be the solution because obviously if
you go here we're not gonna take the
bishop and let you go make a queen how
are we gonna hear the little kids no
right that's good is that okay I
actually might put the podium a little
bit closer if that's that's cool dude
just so that it picks up maybe on the
mic right yeah it won't affect you but
yeah we got kids crying I don't want to
I don't want to yeah my kid didn't get
to go to this class tonight I'm kind of
sad I don't know he's busy busy man very
busy
you're very busy at 4:00 no I don't
think it's made him cry it's made to run
away but that's you know I mean it's
it's born game it's a boring game who
would ever want to play chess sure so
let's just get ourselves to the corner
Wow it was interesting sound did you
like that sound no let's just get
ourselves to the corner we're just we're
just gonna get to the corner okay so if
we achieve this position we'll even all
right we're really really close to
making a queen you'll never actually be
able to get the King to move out of
there so that you can make a queen now
if the bishop were a different color you
would be able to go protect the pawn
with your king then check the King out
of the corner and you'd be able to force
your way in you know you could keep the
pawn here and you can imagine you get
your Queen your king over here but it's
it's not the right color so in this
let's just I'm just gonna keep waiting
in the corner you can get as close as
you want with any of your your pieces
but you'll notice you're never going to
be able to push so whose turn is it here
okay so let's go to the corner and so
even if we get here you'll notice you
can never force me out of here so right
now I don't have any turns to move so if
you tried to get closer you're gonna end
up stale mating the black king the King
just stays in the corner and you're
never able to force them out and so I
mean you can leave the pawn here and try
to do the same thing but okay I just
stay in the corner and if you ever end
up trying to attack that square it's
gonna be stalemate so even if you you
wait for me to go to that Square
voluntarily and you check me I'm gonna
go back to the corner and I have no
moves so if you keep your Bishop on this
diagonal it's gonna be stalemate so it's
a very cool defensive trick to know
about even though you have a pawn and a
bishop you are unable to win the game if
you know the bishop where the other
color would be a lot easier because you
would put your Bishop on this diagonal
and then the king would be forced to run
towards the a file you know you'd be
forced to go in that
direction so so very very cool element
in the position and that's sort of like
part of the beauty of these studies is
there's you know usually you know kind
of what you're doing now but it's it's
always really rewarding when you're able
to solve a study you know even one of
this complexity that I think is
challenging for any class player I think
it's it's not a an easy puzzle at all if
it even is a puzzle maybe there's no
right name maybe it's a drawable nose
yeah yeah I think I've set this one up
right now the more I look at it the more
I think I know what the answer is so
yeah so again we're just we're thinking
back in this position and we're we're
just trying to figure out where we need
that Bishop we're calculating the race
so just in my head I've already
visualized the King here the bishop is
somewhere I play h4 and then it's black
to move and then so if you can figure
out the diagonal the square that you're
gonna need to prevent the King from
going to you can solve this so does
anybody we've had a little bit of time
knows anybody have any possible guesses
or does anybody actually solved it
do you Bishop g4 okay so good this way
it so as black I mean I've got to go to
the corner so I'll go here okay I'll go
here so yeah are you thinking about if I
go here you can cut me off with a king I
assume that was your little trick but
yeah I don't care about your bishop I'm
just trying to get to the corner so
hopefully I can make it now yeah did you
have an idea Bishop g2 okay so if I take
you're gonna push to make a queen so I
don't take it okay
did you have an idea here no you had no
idea you know and so now I guess if you
push I mean I'm coming in yeah even if
you cut me off you know please take my
bishop nope I run to the corner and it's
gonna be a draw
miss Tripp do seven okay I go here
uh-huh oh here
or no ABS just joking just joking I'll
go here oh yeah if you're here okay over
here
okay I will go here
I'm gonna beat you with a stick that's a
violent class nice oh I'm glad my kid
isn't there it sounds like it's getting
pretty violent yeah you following me Ben
Simon
parent parents are incensed poor and
Revere do you want to play with the
night Bishop e8 okay I'm gonna try to
get to that corner
yeah and that's that's the solution yeah
Michael fugu chef so there's really no
good move here for black then your next
move is to push again I have to move
away so you can go here and then you
push in your next move is making a queen
okay have my bishop that's when you guys
yeah Michael puka champ you got that
Julian yeah Michael showed you up he
showed you up I have very good job and
so that the integral part of this and I
believe you can actually do this in in
either order so the problems cooked but
you know it's a richer pointer suggested
puzzle so if you do this in either order
if you had seen you know while the king
is is marching all the way up to the
corner that the square you're gonna need
to take away it doesn't want me to make
colors anymore all right is g6 is it
changed is it are they different buttons
now in this new computer it's just it's
just been a long week I can't remember
the buttons that stuff is g6 and you
have your pawn obviously on this square
then the King will be cut off have to
move away and you'll be able to push the
pawn so excellent a fantastic job I'm
impressed that the audience was was able
to solve it and now what happened - okay
so Julian took an hour he finally
figured it out and then he showed it to
bar it's a okay bar here's the puzzle
yeah one second yeah it's like it's so
easy just Bishop d7 easiest thing he's
ever done in his whole life now so then
Bar was like well here's another puzzle
and so then Barbara is like so not only
that I mean bar he's very well known for
doing lots of studies at the end of lots
of his lectures he's like here's a study
just around the club he'll just come by
there's a study so he does these all the
time he you know he's done thousands and
thousands of studies that's that's his
his thing you know some people really
like studies in it and it goes a long
way to help improving your chess so he
knew this theme pretty well and he's
like well here's another example and so
again we have the defensive resources
it's weight to move and win but as black
if we think about giving our opponent
the move obviously I need to run to this
this corner somehow I can go over my
pawn under my pond
just so we somehow I had checked to get
to that corner and secure a draw so this
is a little bit trickier because you
have to take in mind that the black King
has two separate paths to the queening
square but again it's the same sort of
thing that we're thinking about in our
head so in our head our Bishop is
probably gonna move somewhere I guess I
suppose you can also try marching in
with the King but we need to get the
bishop out at some point so that we're
able to push our pond so you kind of
think of it the same way the bishop goes
away so we imagine what will black do
probably go here and then in our head we
got this position and then we can start
to to figure out the race here so the
black will keep approaching the pond
either by going to e6 and around the
pond that way or by going to e8 and
running to the square behind the pond
this is a win for white okay good Mike
Michael you solved it already it's a win
for away I hope so otherwise I got the
puzzle wrong
it's supposed to be a win for white
there's no way wet
there's no way black can catch it like
so I can just make any move let me just
make some random move you're saying
there's no way I can get here all right
I'll go this way
no bush I'm in the box
oops I can't draw yours anymore
so I'm in the box so I should be able to
catch it you know if you just push in
and I can go either way
so I do catch the pot which is important
so I I do
just get there so if you just move some
random square I will get there in time
okay so you're gonna try to beat me
you're gonna get to the corner before I
do okay here I go
your trip King III okay I will go
underneath King d4 okay here I go
all right I like my chances
and I and I win the race yeah and I just
stay in the corner there's nothing you
can do even though I have this pawn so
it's not you don't have to immediately
stalemate me if you move somewhere you
can do funny stuff cuz I stuff upon but
eventually it'll it'll be a draw I just
stay in the corner but I mean that's one
of the things that when you first see
this position you want to think about
because obviously if if the White King
makes it all the way here well then it's
it's pretty easy we can even use our
Bishop to go to like d6 force the black
King to stay away away away get our pawn
closer get our King out of the way and
make it clean so that is one of the you
know an important thing to to consider
Bishop e7 okay oh yeah actually we
thought I'd go here all right you're in
my path so I guess I'll take you you
don't like your chances anymore yeah I
think I'm gonna get there so you are
trying to figure out the path that the
black King will take so there should be
seven
okay so you could have gotten to pitch
there in one go we decided to go like
that
I guess I'll I guess above this way I
think I can go the other way too in this
position or earlier okay so the oops
the thought is Bishop c5 okay so your is
there any square in particularly you're
trying to block out with this move I
you're gonna so we're not horribly
worried about this pawn because our King
is definitely in the box so I mean I'm
black certainly doesn't have time to
start pushing this this pawn because
we'll we'll get serious about our own
pond and we shouldn't have too many
issues but okay Bishop c5 is an
interesting try thing about Bishop d6
okay certainly seems to be annoying it
looks like it does get some very good
squares but I go here
and I will take your Bishop at something
should be five your tricky guy looks
like I can take it too right
just a laugh at you
and them in the box yeah but if I Mouse
slip but if I mouse slip then you're
then you're in good shape
what do I have what are you saying and
this will go all the way back will go
all the way back okay and you're gonna
go to c7
okay so I'll do the same thing you want
to immediately or do you want to push up
on you wanna go here immediately okay
really don't me to go there okay so I
got a light squared path to the corner
so I'm just four moves away from
achieving my dream here and okay so it's
simple in the sense that there's not
very many pieces on the board but these
are very very difficult you wanna do
king of two again
okay well really if King up two will see
the big improvement now Bishop d6 okay I
will attack you we're gonna be eight
alright I sorry and again I have a light
squared path to the corner so it is you
have to be really really quick the black
king is just running to that corner very
very quick so you do need to figure out
where you need to be to cut off the king
it's it's incredibly difficult so so
just the king is just too slow so moving
the King initially it just doesn't work
we need to get the upon into the game
the pawn has to get down there and make
a queen as soon as possible so what's
that
Bishop to c5 okay I will go here
a4 okay excellent move let me run the
other way for uh for a little fun I'll
have a little fun we'll go the other way
yeah okay I got here
a six well I can't take the bishop
because now you're making a queen but I
don't I don't need to win the bishop I
just need to get to the corner so I'm on
my way that's why you wanna bring the
king closer okay try to get closer to
that corner and and a funny move is this
check but it doesn't work I just go here
so we are getting mr. BAE seven very
good okay so this is sort of the idea
okay I'll wait and you wanna bring the
king in and then I want to go here
you want to move the bishop let's say in
this position you don't wanna go here to
laugh at me alright I got here I'm in
the corner so we're getting very close
so I my feeling is that and again if
you're just joining us I don't really
know this puzzle I'm figuring it out too
I can run this way and make it to the
corner because again if we just keep
going here a little bit
it looks like I do get there just in
time because even if you go here I have
a move like King to be five so we're
we're getting very very close we're
starting to get some of the ideas here
on the board but we're just not quite
there it should be four okay
for me for
I okay I can go two ways let me go this
way here
Oh
I'll go here
before a 600 Jetix might be 6 or d6 yeah
so yeah d6 I go here I can also go there
in which position you want to go back
let's go back to Bishop b4 okay
and I went here there's 56 there you go
here okay
yeah shoot okay and if you try the other
way okay good idea
okay so I'm gonna right now above the
top this time uh-huh hey five okay
uh-huh
a seven here
do you see why we should be
so we got Bishop c5 Bishop d6 suggested
mm-hmm in this position earlier right
here okay I will go here take your bun
so close we're so close that look at
this a little more carefully there's
room a5 yeah brilliant and I'm I'm cut
off so I can no longer make any more
progress I don't know if you solved this
one so Jillian I think he got this
puzzle I wasn't really watching any of
this otherwise I would know a lot more
about this puzzle this is chess face 12
so that's good because everybody always
asks I might as well say it every video
we're using chess space it's chess base
12 which in my opinion that's better
than 13
I've just had better experiences with 12
then 13 but uh but yeah that's what we
use for all of these these lectures and
this indeed is the thing so okay but
okay let me just make a move for example
here just to see if it's not so easy
it's not so easy we just just to make
sure we understand the winning idea now
it's no way to move yep I'll just pass
basically I played d6 can you have two
yeah okay okay and the King just gets
closer and closer and eventually I have
to move out of the way and whenever I
have to move out of the way you push
because now you're close enough and I
can't stop you
so this is indeed the solution let's
just go ahead and ask our buddy machine
see if it well okay and so again you'll
just run this through with with our
buddy
the engine this is for its 11 for some
reason so okay it wants to go this way
and it says that you're losing it
doesn't see the mate yet so here's the
computer line for if you run this way
and okay it stops you and it gives a
really big number and if on the other
hand you were to run behind the pond the
same sort of thing
a5 or Bishop d6 seem to work if you go
here which it doesn't do for some reason
which is funny in Bishop d6 as the
audience did figure out and if here a
six mate and 14 so eventually you'll
just ring your king a little closer
you'll as soon as this King moves away
on the next move you you know you you go
make a queen so that was perfect so
those are really tough unfortunately
that does do it for time for us tonight
so I think I think these puzzles will -
because they're they're really tough you
know that's it's so simple there's just
a couple pieces but some of these can be
some of the trickiest and most
challenging things to do in chess and I
would encourage people that if you are
interested you can just look up there's
like endgame databases with thousands of
studies it's out there on the internet
if you're if you're interested in doing
this sort of thing and and if you really
put the time in you know you'll feel
very good whenever you're able to solve
any one of them no matter how easy it is
like an easy study means maybe you know
it's easy for an expert or a master but
they're very challenging